I mean first of all I mean 80 per
theater I mean I've made eighty dollars
in a theater and there wasn't even a
movie playing wow what do you mean I
don't know
you know it's no surprise who would go
see the movie that's the opposite of
entertaining there's nothing
entertaining about that Michael Morris
colonoscopy is more entertaining than
that because there's probably more
twists but it does show you how great it
is to be a progressive in a liberal
biased culture she really doesn't do her
job right she makes movies she goes to
gala's she sits for glossy butt kissing
uh interviews and GQ and other women's
mags uh once you get over the fact that
you're hollow inside it's not a bad life
all right Dana well I think that the I
read a little bit of the New York Times
review
uh Teo he thinks that the hopelessness
of the movie makes it a hard sell for
people who would go see the movie and
also for voters to change their minds
about climate change but they said for
AOC that she offers the best on-screen
antidote to despair because she's funny
a cunning a canny political strategy but
they don't like it if conservatives are
funny
I thought there was an audience for this
outside of like Earth Justice for the
Justice Democrats because who really
wanted to go and see this thing and then
tomorrow you'll have an article that
we'll have to talk about which is that
kids all over America are having
nightmares about climate change well no
wonder
um
Jessica what about the fact that the
climate activists are very much I mean
they're very much enthused about what
they do and you know they do all kinds
of things to get attention I mean
they're willing to get run over on the
highways and get their skin glued to in
museums why aren't they at least showing
a uh watching a movie
they're cheap people go to the theater
anymore
I mean they do for like a top gun or the
Marvel movies are really successful but
in the certainly the post covet era
everyone wants to watch everything at
home especially something that's like
that you know she had a Netflix
documentary uh three years ago three
four years ago right after she won with
some other progressives called knock
down the house and I think that was
really highly viewed because people
could just sit around and watch it you
want to turn it off because you want to
grab dinner come back turn it back on
but the most successful climate
documentary was Al Gore's An
Inconvenient Truth and it only made 24
million dollars this is not the best
like the biggest one the coldest day of
the year I'll never forget it
inconvenience today as a press secretary
all right Jesse would would you go to
this movie
would I go to it no have I seen it no
will I talk about it yes so
as a product in the marketplace AOC no
one wants to buy that yeah so this is
what politicians often get confused
about just because you're popular in
politics doesn't mean you're popular
anywhere else in fact usually people
that can't do anything anywhere else go
into politics to succeed and she found
out that way the hard way what's
fraudulent about this is because she's
trying to sell herself as some hiker
I she where did she grow up again
Westchester Westchester she represents
queens and she wears plaid and then she
has little ski things with like a 60
pound backpack like she does that I have
never seen and she showcases her whole
life on social media you can never see
her in private everything is on social
media I've never seen her hike before
but the one time she does a documentary
about the environment she's out there
doing the Appalachian Trail I'm not
buying it